MATTHEW CHANCE IS OUT FRONT.
>> Reporter: UKRAINE'S GAIN HERE
SET TO DRAMATIC MUSIC BY THEIR
OWN TROOPS IS INCREASING PUTIN'S
LOSS.
RUSSIA'S STUNNING MILITARY
SETBACKS STIRRING BROAD PUBLIC
CRITICISM AT HOME, WHICH SHOCKED
MILITARY HARDLINERS VOICING
ANGER.
>> HI, I'M DIMITRY.
>> Reporter: AND DOZENS OF
ELECTED LOCAL RUSSIAN
POLITICIANS TOO SIGNING AN
OFFICIAL PETITION OFFERED BY
THIS LOCAL CHANCELLOR DEMANDING
PRESIDENT PUTIN BE IMPEACHED.
RUSSIA FINES PEOPLE FOR SPEAKING
OUT.
>> WELL, OBVIOUSLY RUSSIAN ARMY
IS BEING DESTROYED RIGHT NOW.
SO, WE'LL LOSE PEOPLE, WE'LL
LOSE WEAPONS, AND WE'LL LOSE OUR
ABILITY TO DEFEND.
>> Reporter: AND THAT FACT THAT
THE RUSSIAN ARMY IS SUFFERING
THESE SETBACKS, THAT IS FUELING
ANGER, ISN'T IT, NOT JUST
AMONGST LIBERAL ASPECTS OF
RUSSIAN SOCIETY BUT ALSO AMONGST
HARD LINERS AS WELL.
THEY'RE FURIOUS.
>> YEAH.
ACTUALLY PRO WAR ACTIVISTS NOW
REALLY FEEL BETRAYED.
AND THERE IS A POINT WHERE BOTH
LIBERAL GROUP OF PEOPLE AND PRO
WAR GROUP OF PEOPLE CAN HAVE THE
SAME GOAL.
>> Reporter: AND LIKE THESE
EARLY ANTIWAR PROTESTERS IN
MOSCOW BACK IN FEBRUARY, HARD
LINERS COMPLAIN OF RUSSIA BEING
TOO SOFT ON UKRAINE AND SENDING
WOEFULLY UNDERPREPARED TROOPS
INTO BATTLE.
BUT IT'S THE HEAVY PRICE RUSSIA
IS PAYING WHERE THERE MAY BE
COMMON CAUSE.
>> HI, MY NAME IS --
>> Reporter: AND WHY ANOTHER
RUSSIAN COUNSELOR CALLED FOR
PUTIN TO RESIGN.
THE KREMLIN STRONGMAN, SHE TOLD
ME, IS DEPRIVING RUSSIANS OF A
FUTURE.
>> RUSSIANS HAVE BECOME POOR,
THEY ARE NOT WELCOME ANYWHERE.
AND THERE IS LESS OF FACILITIES,
SUPPLIES.
RUSSIA DOESN'T REALLY PRODUCE
ANYTHING ITSELF.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT FUTURE CAN
BE FOR THE COUNTRY WHICH IS
ISOLATED.
>> CAN YOU TALK TO ME ABOUT WHAT
IMPACT THAT LACK OF A FUTURE IS
HAVING ON PEOPLE THAT YOU SPEAK
TO?
>> AH, WELL, IT'S QUITE
DEPRESSING NOW, VERY DEPRESSING
ATMOSPHERE IN RUSSIA, AND THE
FRUSTRATION FEELING FEAR, ANGER,
SHAME.
>> THE KREMLIN INSISTS THE MOOD
OF THE PEOPLE IS STILL WITH THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT.
BUT THE GROWING CRITICISM AT
HOME AND ABROAD MAY AT LEAST
THREATEN TO TAKE THE SWAGGER OUT
OF PUTIN'S STEP.
>> WELL, ERIN, TONIGHT, AT LEAST
70 RUSSIAN LOCAL POLITICIANS
HAVE NOW SIGNED THE PETITION FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO RESIGN, WHICH
IS AN EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH
NUMBER IN A COUNTRY WHICH NEVER
REALLY DID BUT CERTAINLY NO
LONGER TOLERATES PUBLIC DISSENT,
LET ALONE OFFICIAL DISSENT FROM
THE KREMLIN LINE.
THE FIVE POLITICIANS THAT CALLED
FOR HIS IMPEACHMENT, THEY'VE
BEEN FINED.
BUT THE KREMLIN ISN'T TAKING
REALLY STRONG ACTION AGAINST
HIM, AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
TELLING OF THE SENSITIVITY IN
RUSSIA RIGHT NOW.
>> MATTHEW CHANCE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
AND THAT PETITION MATTHEW IS
REFERRING TO, JUST 72 HOURS AGO
THERE WERE 25 BRAVE SIGNATORIES.
NOW, DESPITE, RIGHT, THOSE
FINES, 70?
THAT SAYS SOMETHING.
AND I WANT TO BRING IN STEVE
HALL, THE FORMER CIA CHIEF OF
RUSSIA OPERATIONS BASED IN
MOSCOW.
SO, STEVE, YOU HEAR MATTHEW TALK
ABOUT THIS LAYING OUT THE RISE
IN DISSENT IN RUSSIA RIGHT NOW
THAT IS GROWING.
SO WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THIS?
>> WELL, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE THINGS
OBVIOUSLY WORK DIFFERENTLY IN
RUSSIA THAN THEY DO IN A PLACE
THAT HAS A DEMOCRACY LIKE THE
UNITED STATES OR ANY OF THE
EUROPEAN UNION COUNTRIES.
THERE IS NO DEMOCRACY IN RUSSIA.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE SPEAKING
OUT LIKE THIS, FIRST OF ALL,
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT VERY
CAREFULLY.
BUT PUTIN ISN'T PARTICULARLY, I
DON'T THINK, WORRIED ABOUT THEM.
HE'S GOT SPIES ALL AROUND THEM.
HE'S A FORMER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER.
HE KNOWS THE IMPORTANCE OF
SPYING ON DISSIDENTS AND
CONTROLLING THEIR ACTIONS SO HE
KNOWS WHAT THEY'RE UP TO AND
HE'S PROBABLY GOT THEM UNDER
CONTROL BECAUSE HE CAN SIMPLY
THROW THEM IN JAIL ANY TIME HE
WANTS.
THAT'S WHAT HE DOES IS HE
REPRESSES.
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER GROUP OF
PEOPLE, THESE ARE CLOSE ADVISERS
TO PUTIN, IT COMES FROM THE
RUSSIAN WORD FOR POWER.
THESE ARE LIKE THE HEAD OF THE
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE, SOME
SENIORS IN THE MILITARY.
AND WHEN THEY START NOTICING
THESE PEOPLE SPEAKING OUT IN
RUSSIA, THEN THEY BEGIN TO GET
WORRIED THAT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
THAT PUTIN HAS PUT TOGETHER,
WHICH THEY BENEFIT FROM, IS
COMING APART.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS IT'S THOSE
PEOPLE THAT GET WORRIED AND
THINK I WONDER IF PUTIN IS THE
RIGHT GUY TO BE THE PRESIDENT
RIGHT NOW.
>> SO I SPOKE THE OTHER DAY WITH
ONE OF THE RUSSIAN POLITICIANS
WHO IS DEMANDING PUTIN'S
RESIGNATION.
HE SAID THAT THESE RUSSIAN
ELITES -- PERHAPS SOME OF THOSE
YOU'RE REFERRING TO BUT ALSO
SOME OF THE OLIGARCH TYPES HE
WAS REFERRING TO, THAT HE SAYS
PUTIN NEEDS.
WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT THEY HAD
BEFORE THE WAR AND THAT THEY ARE
FED UP WITH PUTIN.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> Translator: PUTIN IS VERY
DEPENDENT ON THE ELITES.
HE HE MAKEN THEIR LIVES
DIFFICULT.
ONE SOLUTION IS TO THROW THEM
UNDER THE BUS TO GET BACK THE
LIVES THEY WERE LIVING BEFORE.
>> THROW THEM UNDER THE BUS.
IS THAT ON THE TABLE, DO YOU
THINK, STEVE, FROM WHAT YOU KNOW
SO WELL ABOUT THIS COUNTRY,
SOMETHING SO FAR AS A COUP?
>> SO THE RUSSIAN ECOSYSTEM IS A
DIFFICULT ONE.
I MEAN, THE POLITICAL AND SOCIAL
ECOSYSTEM.
SO YOU'VE GOT OLIGARCHS WHO DO
PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE.
THEY MAKE A LOT OF MONEY NOT
ONLY FOR THEMSELVES BUT ALSO FOR
THE COMPANIES AND FOR RUSSIA AND
OF COURSE IMPORTANTLY FOR PUTIN.
BUT, AGAIN, IT'S NOT THE
OLIGARCHS I THINK THAT ARE GOING
TO RISE UP AGAINST PUTIN.
THEY COULD HELP, THEY COULD
INSTIGATE.
BUT YOU'LL REMEMBER ONE OF THE
PROMINENT OLIGARCHS TEN YEARS
AGO WAS THROWN INTO JAIL FOR
PRECISELY GETTING INTO POLITICS.
AGAIN IT'S THESE CLOSE ADVISERS
TO HIM.
IT'S PEOPLE WHO CONTROL THESE
SECURITY SERVICES, CONTROL THE
POLICE HAVE THEIR HANDS ON THE
LEVER OF POWER AND WHO UP TILL
NOW HAD BEEN DOING WHAT PUTIN
SAYS BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL PART OF
THE SYSTEM THAT EVERYBODY
BENEFITS FROM IF YOU'RE HIGH UP
ENOUGH IN RUSSIA.
BUT, AGAIN, WHEN THINGS START TO
COME APART, THEY'RE GOING TO
THINK BACK TO GORBACHEV IN 1991
WHEN THE SOVIET UNION WAS COMING
APART AND A COUP ATTEMPT WAS
MADE AGAINST HIM.
IT WAS UNSUCCESSFUL.
BUT THERE IS PRECEDENT FOR THIS,
AND I'M SURE PRESIDENT PUTIN
REMEMBERS TH